OLIVER DE WECK:
Concept questions
are a fairly recent
instrument for checking
the understanding of students
in real time during the class.
One way to administer
concept questions
is using clicker systems.
They've been around
for several years.
A concept question is
typically a very short question
that requires either
reflection, or some very simple
calculation, that can be
done in less than a minute.
The concept question is intended
to surface misconceptions,
but also alignment
and understanding.
And I do administer the
concept questions using,
in this case, Google Forms.
But there's other ways to
do it, essentially providing
the students a very short URL--
a link that they can enter
either on their laptops, even
on their smartphones
or on their tablets.
And usually, a concept question
is a multiple choice question.
Sometimes, it's very easy.
Sometimes, it's quite tricky.
And I give the students
about 30 seconds
or so to think about it, work
out an answer, respond online.
And then, once the
answer period is over,
I display the
responses in real time.
And what's nice about it,
in the context of a SPOC,
it doesn't matter
where the students sit,
whether they're with
you in the classroom,
whether they're online.
Everybody has the same link.
So you're getting everybody's
responses at the same time.
So it's a great
mechanism for engagement.
Sometimes, everybody agrees--
100% or 90% agreement.
Everybody chose
the right answer.
And in that case, there's
not much discussion needed.
Because it's clear
that it clicked.
You know the concept
is well understood.
My favorite concept
questions are
the ones where the answers
are all over the map.
You have five possible
choices, and each of them
got close to 20%.
That's great, because now, you
have a hook for discussion.
So I would then,
if that happens.
spend the next three,
four, five minutes
in the class
reiterating the concept,
and then asking students,
who voted for A?
Who voted for B?
Why did you do that?
What was your opinion?
And so you get a great
discussion going,
which, again, can have
the in-classroom, and then
the online component, as well.
We also use the chat during
those post-concept questions.
And it's a great
way to activate it.
And there's a
second reason I also
do concept questions,
at least one
during lecture, which is, it's
a great way to track attendance.
And I'm up front with
the students about this.
Because you can see the time
tag when students responded.
So you know exactly who
responded to the chat
during the class.
And I do use that for
participation grading.